僕は30歳の時に全くの素人の状態から
チョコレートづくりを始めました
それまでの30年間の僕の経験は全く役に
立たず毎日が困ったことの連続です
素人であった僕がチョコレートづくりを
始めたきっかけは
あるときに食べた1枚のチョコレートの
衝撃からです
見た目は
まったく普通のチョコレートと変わらない
それを食べた時に
まるでオレンジのような鮮やかな柑橘の味
がしました
聞いてみると
カカオ豆とお砂糖を描い何も使っていない
その鮮やかなオレンジみたいな味はどう
やら
コロンビア産のカカオ豆の味だということ
を教えてもらいました
まるでワインのようにカカオ豆の産地に
よって味が全然変わるんだって言った衝撃
がその後の僕の人生を大きく変えていき
ましたチョコレートの最小限はカカオ豆で
ある
このことを知って
ワインのように彼母前の味わいを表現した
チョコレートを作ろうと決めた僕は調べて
みると
カカオ豆はチョコレートのイメージからは
全く
離れている
赤道直下の南国のフルーツの誰だという
ことがわかります
カカオ豆をもっと知りたいなと思って
そこから僕は毎年カカオ農園に通い始め
ます
カカオ農園に行ってみると
そこにはチョコレートの甘くない真実が
ありました
カカオとチョコレートの産業構造は植民地
貿易の構造を引きずってい
カカオ農園は極めて貧困であったりとか
西アフリカの一部では児童の強制労働
みたいなゲームですがまだ残っています
良いカカオ豆を c 0
従来の画一的な味ではないチョコレートを
作っていきたいと思っていたので
最低の価格を地上角度る高いフェア
トレードというところを定めて時に地上の
科学の2倍とか3倍とか4倍とかという
高いお金を払ってきちんと個性的なカカオ
を仕入れるというビジネスをやろうと僕が
決めました
高い価格を払ってよい豆を買う
息を様と僕は農家に買い付けに行きました
高いお金を払えば農家の収入も増えるし
きっとみんな僕に賛同してくれるはずだと
いうふうに思って
います
でも僕の最初の大きな困った壁が
現実としてそこに立ちはだかりました
僕はカカオのをから
カカは豆を買うことができなかったんです
それはなぜかというと僕が量を変えなかっ
たんです
カカオの価格はロンドンとかニューヨーク
のマーケットで先物市場で決まります
質の良いまでも悪い豆もテーマを
めちゃめちゃかけたままでも手を抜いた豆
も極端な話て言うと同じなんなんです
カカオ農家はずっと昔から
儲けるためにはたくさん寮を作らないと
いけないっていう商売をしてきました
僕が3倍のなんでジャビットんかいますね
って言ってもいやいやうちは昔から100
トンをつくっているから三分の一の値段で
100丼等が儲かるんだというふうに言わ
れて僕に豆を売ってくれませんです
高いお金を払ってよいものが買えるはずだ
農家の収入も増えるはずだって僕が思って
た
連日が音を立てて崩れていって僕は
ハンマーで殴られたぐらい衝撃を受けます
どうしよう
豆が全く変えない
僕の最初の大きな困ったという壁はある
ひとりの農家との出会いによって変わって
いきました
インドネシアに
ある生産者団体に買い付けに行ったとき
です
30ぐらいの農家が集まった生産版タイ
デー
29の農家は僕と取引をしてくれないと
いう風
その中で
一つの農家が僕の取引を始めるというふう
に決めてくれました僕は彼になんで僕たち
と取引を始めてくれるんですかという風に
聞いてみます
はこういったんです
僕は40年間カカオ農家をやってきた
40年間やって初めて君たちが自分の
カカオ豆でチョコレートを作って食べさし
区
そしたら自分のカカオ豆がこんなに
おいしいチョコレートになるんだって僕は
感動さん
君たちと一緒に質を高めていったら僕の
カカオ豆がもっとおいしいキー
チョコレートになるっていう
可能性があることにワクワクした
それに加えて
僕はずーっと料デー
取引をしていっ
量で取引をしないといけないということは
朝から晩まで重要度をずっとしないといけ
正直僕は自分の子どもたちにこの農家を
釣らせるということをしたくなかっ
僕と同じように朝から晩まで苦労して働く
ということを子供たちにさせたくなかっ
でも量ではない室っていう選択肢で少量で
ちゃんと収入を上げていくということが
できるかもしれないという未来が初めて僕
エアベル4んだから僕は君たちと仕事をし
たい
僕は正直この言葉を聞いた時にとても大事
なことを教えてもらったと思います
人生を豊かにすることっていうのは自分で
選択をできることなんだというふうに
気づきます
これまでカカオ農家というのは寮での取引
という選択しかなかったんですが
僕がいつどういう選択肢を提示すると量と
質っていうものを自分で選ぶことができ
僕はどこかで自分は高いお金で農家に高
収入になっていくことを選択肢を呈して
いるのですごくいいことだっているんだ
っていうふうに思っていたと僕は思います
でもそんなことはなくて僕にできることは
足常取引をするという選択肢をフラットに
提示をすることだけだん
選ぶのあくまで no 語って
農家が決めている
僕の買い付けのスタンスは変わっていき
ました
高いお金を払ってよいものを買うという
買い付けじゃなくて質っていう選択肢を
提示して
農家と一緒に未来をつくって郵送いう仲間
を探す
仲間探しに買い付けのスタンスを変えた後
に少しずつ僕にカカオの豆を売ってくれる
農家が出てきました
そうしたことによって
僕は今では15カ国30農家以上の仲間が
世界中できました
カカオの現場に行って自分の困ったを解決
して言って僕ですが僕にとってもう一つ
とても大事な現場がありますそれは日本の
店舗でお客さんとコミュニケーションをし
ながらチョコレートを打っていくという
僕の創業当初の一番大きな不安や困ったわ
チョコレートの販売価格でした10倍以上
の価格差があるものが売れるのか
この大きな不安であったり困ったが僕に
立ち上がります
これを解決してくれたのは
店舗でのお客さんとのやりとりです
毎週僕たちのテンポに通ってもらって
3枚から5枚複数枚買ってくれる
20代後半の女性のお客さんが
いらっしゃいましたある時に僕がお客さん
に聞いてみたんですね毎週なんで買って
くれるんです
そしたら彼女はこう言いました私は丸の内
で働いているんですが
ランチをすると1500円から2000円
かかりますそれをお弁当すれば
チョコレートを変えるじゃないですか
香りの豊かなから少量取得理由食べるだけ
でとても幸せな気持ちになるんです
仕事で疲れた時とか何か嫌なことがあった
時にチョコレートを一かでかじるだけで
前向きな気持ちになれるし
また週末に今度はどんなチョコレートを
買おうって思うだけでワクワクして毎日が
頑張れます
そして山下さんとかスタッフの皆さんから
このチョコレートはこんな農家さんが作っ
てるんだよとか
このチョコレートをこんなコーヒーとか
こんなお酒に合わせると美味しくなります
よみたいな情報を教えてもらえると自分の
おいしいチョコレートがもっとより
美味しく感じてワクワクするストーリーが
生まれてくる
私にとってはコストパフォーマンスを
めちゃくちゃ高いです
僕はこの素晴らしい言葉を頂いた時に
10倍の価格差
で入れるのかっていうことよりもっと大切
なことはあ
自分たちが提供しているものがその科学に
見る価値をお客さん提供できているのかと
言うとか家に向き合うということの方が
大事なんだということを教えてもらえます
だから
8ない努力をすることは当たり前で良い豆
を仕入れ手間を掛けて作っ
超時期おいしいというのはお客さんが
決めることです
からこそお客さんにそう思ってもらえれば
その先においしい以上の価値
お客さんの人生を頂いする何かを提供
できるかもしれないという可能性に僕は
気づかせてまいります
もう一人のお客さんと出会いがその気づき
をさらに確信に変えてくれます
ある夏に女性のお客様からお手紙を
いただきます
土地が明けた次の2月のバレンタインに
旦那様に1のチョコレートを送ってほしい
というご依頼の受け売りですね
そのお客様は
4名が2ヶ月
もしかすると次のバレンタインには
自分はこの世の中にいないかもしれんその
時に旦那様にチョコレートを送って落
その奥様はすごく
チョコレートを食べるのが好きで旦那様を
ヲチ8回していろんなチョコレート
食べ歩き教えたラジ
旦那さんは実は甘いものを積極的に食べる
タイプじゃなかったんですかものすごく
美味しいと言って二人で楽しく食べたと
いう思い出があったん
なので彼女は人生の最後に送るかもしれ
ないチョコレートに僕たちのチョコレート
を贈りたい
自分がただ食べておいしいだけじゃなくて
旦那さんと楽しい思い出を共有したその
チョコレートを贈りたいんだっていう風に
お手紙に書いていただきました
当然僕はものすごく嬉しかったんですけど
正直
もしかしたら自分は
とんでもない仕事を選んでしまったかもな
って言う
驚きと不安が大きかった
食べるものっていうのは
当然美味しいという価値を提供しますし
でもそれ以上に食べた瞬間とか食べた人と
の思い出が宿るものなんだというふうに
思いました
中途半端なものを作ったらそれはその人に
とって悪い影響を与える告知
逆に良いモノを作ればそれは美味しい以上
にその人の人生を豊かにすることができる
コツ
仮に豊かに出来るとしたらそんなに幸せな
仕事はないなっていうふうに僕は思います
だからこそ
ものづくりに終わりはなくて
一生懸命作っていくことイーストに出会う
こと
その時の最大限の努力で最高のものをお
届け
その最高のものをお客さんに始まってくれ
そのフィードバックを受けながらそれを次
のものづくり歓迎していくということを a
に繰り返していくということがものづくり
の責任だということを僕は思います
そういうことをしていくとか彼をもうか
さんと僕たちとお客さという
それぞれに小さな幸せを提供することが
できて
みんながちょっとだけ幸せになる
happy cycle mita もの
が生まれていくこれは農家さんから国や
そしてお客さんにつづくハート to
ハートのつながりをつくっていくことが
できるんだというふうに思います
そうすることによって僕たちの仕事は少し
だけ世界を
良くすることができるかもしれん
1枚のチョコレートからつながった
僕の世界はどんどん広がっていって世界中
に仲間が出来ましたカカオと貯古齢糖とし
て僕は人生のかけがえのない教訓を得まし
たし
カカオの味わいを表現するチョコレート
づくりを広げていくことは人生を賭けるに
値する仕事なんだなっていうふうな
ことを思います
僕の困ったわ
つまらない固定観念から来てました
高い価格を払えば良いものが買えるという
おごりだったり
10倍の科学さあで見れるのかという不安
だったいっ
でもそれは
カカオ農家さんやお客さんとの
コミュニケーションの中で
まるでチョコレートのように溶けてなく
なります
困ったに対する自分なりの解決方法はあり
ますかという問いに対して
僕は今こう答えます
困った先にある現場に行って
現実を知って
そこにいるリアルな人と
コミュニケーションすることで必ず解決の
糸口が見つかっていきそれが解決の方向
つながっていきます今の世の中は
インターネットで簡単に情報が取れますで
もその情報を分かった気にならずにその
情報の裏側にある真実やその情報の本当の
意味を
リアルな現場に行って自分が開館して知っ
ていくっていうことを大切にしてほしいな
というふうに思います
今
cobit ナインティーンで世界は
大きな困ったに直面しています
僕たちもその影響でとても大きな困ったに
直面しています
でもぼくたちの大切な現場の一つであるお
客さんとのコミュニケーションを重ねて
いくことによって
少しずつこの困ったに対する解決の糸口が
見つかってきていますそしてもう少し
cobit 9ティングをついたら僕は
もう一つの大切な現場である
カカオ生産者カカオ農家に会いに行きたい
なというふうに思いますチョコレートの
業界ではカカオの豆からチョコレートを
作ることをビンテーバーというふうに言い
ます
僕はこれを
カカオ農家と僕らとお客さんの心と心の
つながりだというふうに思っています
心と心がつながればコミュニケーションを
豊かになります
僕が初めてチョコレートを食べた時に本当
に驚きました
そんな驚きを
僕たちのチョコレート通してみなさんの
人生のフレーバーとしてお届けが出来たら
最高です